Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today you are going to see how Google’s new
AI just supercharged art generation. Again!
Yes, this year, we are entering the age
of AI-based art generation. OpenAI’s
DALL-E 2 technique is able to
take a piece of text from us,
and generate a stunning image
that matches this description.
Stable Diffusion, a similar, but open source
technique is also now available for everyone
to use. And the results are so good that artists
are already using it around the world to create
illustrations for a novel, texture synthesis
for virtual worlds, product design, and more.
So, are we done here? Is there
nothing else to improve other
than the visual fidelity of
the results? Well, not quite!
Have a look at two of my favorite
AI-generated images, this scholar
who is desperately trying to hold on to his
papers. So, I am very happy with this image,
but imagine that if we were creating a comic,
we would need more images of this chap doing
other things. Can we do that? Well, we
are experienced Fellow Scholars here,
so, we know that variant generation comes
to the rescue, right? Well, have a look.
Clearly, the AI has an understanding of the image,
and can create somewhat similar images: let’s
see - we get someone with a similar beard,
similar paper which is similarly on fire.
The fact that the AI can have a look at such
an image and create variants is a miracle of
science…but not quite what we are looking for.
Why is that? Well, of course,
this is a new scholar. We are looking for
the previous scholar doing other things.
Now let’s try our fox scientist too and see if
this was maybe just an anomaly? Maybe DALL-E 2
is just not into our Scholarly content? Let’s see!
Well, once again, the results are pretty good. It
understood that the huge ears, gloves, labcoat
and the tie are important elements of the image,
but ultimately, this is a different
fox scientist in a different style.
So, no more adventures for these scientists,
right? Have we lost them
forever? Should we give up?
Well, not so fast! Have a look at Google’s new
technique, which promises a solution to this
challenging problem! Yes, they promise that if we
are able to take about 4 images of our subject,
for instance, this good boy here, it
will be able to synthesize completely
new images with them. Let’s see, this
is the same dog in the Acropolis.
That is excellent. However… wait a minute! This
photo is very similar to this one. So basically,
there was a little synthesis going on here,
but otherwise, changing the background carries
the show here. That is now new. We can do
that with already existing tools anyway.
So, is that it? Well, hold on to your
papers, because the answer is no,
it goes beyond changing backgrounds. It
goes so far beyond that that I don’t even
know where to start! For instance, here
is our little doggy swimming, sleeping,
in a bucket, and we can even give this good boy
a haircut. That is absolutely insane. And all of
these new situations were synthesized by using
only 4 input photos. Wow. Now we’re talking!
Similarly, if we have a pair of stylish
sunglasses, we can ask a bear to wear it,
make a cool product photo out of it, or put
it in front of the Eiffel Tower. And as I am
a light transport researcher by trade, I have
to note that even secondary effects, like the
reflection of the glasses here are modeled really
well. And so are the reflections here. Loving it.
But, it can do so much more than this. Here
are 5 of my favorite examples from the paper.
One, we can not only put our favorite teapot
into different contexts, or see it in use,
but we can even reimagine an otherwise
opaque object and see what it would look
like if it were made of a transparent
material, like glass. I love it,
and I bet that product design
people will also love it too.
Two, we can create art renditions of our
test subject. Here, the input is only
three photos of a dog, but the output, the
output is priceless. We can commission art
renditions from legendary artists of the past,
and all this nearly for free. How cool is that?
Three, I hope you liked this teapot property
modification concept, because we are going
to push it quite a bit further! For
instance, before repainting our car,
we can have a closer look at what it would look
like, and we can also reimagine our favorite
little pets as other animals. Which one is
your favorite? Let me know in the comments
below. Mine is the hippo. It has to be
the hippo. Look at how adorable it is!
And if even that is not enough, four, we can also
ask the AI to reimagine our little dog as a chef,
a nurse, a police dog, and many others.
And all of these images are fantastic!
And finally, five it can perform no less than
views synthesis too! We know from previous papers
that this is quite challenging, and this one only
requests four photos of our cat, and of course,
if the cat is refusing to turn the right
direction, which happens basically every time,
well, no matter, the AI can resynthesize an
image of it looking into our desired directions.
This one looks like something straight out of a
science fiction movie. What a time to be alive!
And this is a huge step forward, you see,
previous techniques typically struggled
with this, even in the best cases,
the fidelity of the results suffer. This alarm
clock is not the same as our input photo was.
And neither is this one. But, with the new
technique, now we’re talking! Bravo Google!
And once again, don’t forget, the First
Law of Papers is on full display here:
this huge leap happened just one more paper
down the line. I am truly stunned by these
results and I cannot even imagine what we will
be able to do 2 more papers down the line!
So, what do you think? What would you use
this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!